welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka and in this
episode we'll share the recipe to plan a
warm dr pattern for your applications
that are deployed on-premise so let's
dive in
[Music]
a little recap in the last episode we
were talking about Main Street art that
runs their applications on premise and
are building a DR infrastructure on
Google Cloud and we helped them set up a
cold dr plan for Main Street
art has changed a bit since then they
now need to set up a forum stand by dr
pattern to keep the RTO and RPO values
as small as possible without the effort
and expense of a full EHA configuration
which means to support a disaster they
need some replication and redundancy
built into the system well let's see how
this would work we create a VPC network
then we configure the connectivity
between the on-premise network and the
google cloud network we replicate the
on-premise servers to the compute engine
instances then create snapshots of the
web and application server instances we
then create a custom image of the
database server on Google cloud with the
same configuration as on-premise then we
start a database instance in Google
cloud using that custom image and attach
a persistent disk to the instance for
database and transaction logs we can
figure the replication of the database
server set auto delete flag on the
persistent disk to know auto-delete we
do this so that our persistent disk will
not be inadvertently deleted since that
would be a disaster configure a
scheduled task to create regular
snapshots of the persistent disk of the
database instance on google cloud then
test the process of creating instances
from the snapshots by creating the web
and application server also create
script that copies updates to the web
application and the application server
whenever the corresponding on-premise
servers are updated write the script to
create a snapshot of the updated servers
then configure cloud dns to point to the
internet facing web service on-premise
then a disaster hits all main street art
needs to do is to Reese
the database server instance to handle
the production load use the web and
application server snapshots to create
new web and application server instances
and then test that it all works once
tested point the cloud DNS to their web
service on Google cloud when the
production environment is running on
premise again and can support production
workloads main street art has to reverse
the steps that they followed during the
failover a typical sequence to return to
the production environment is we take a
backup of the database running on Google
cloud then copy and apply the backup
files to the database in the production
environment then we prevent connections
to the application in Google Cloud one
way to do this is to prevent connections
to the web server by modifying the
firewall rules from this point the
application will be unavailable until we
finish restoring the production
environment don't forget to copy any
transaction log files over to the
production environment and apply to the
database in that environment test that
the application works as expected by
simulating the user scenarios on the
production environment configure cloud
DNS to point to the on-premise web
service then delete the web server and
the application server instances that
are running in Google Cloud resize the
database server on Google Cloud back to
the minimum instance size that can
accept replicated data from the
on-premise production database then
configure replication between on-premise
database server and the database server
in Google Cloud by following the
instructions for your specific database
software well there you have it if you
are running your application on-premise
and need to keep the RTO and RPO values
as small as possible without the expense
of a full EHA configuration then a
warmed er pattern is the way to go we
learned how to approach recovering the
environment from failure in a
DR scenario that's all for today on get
cooking in crowd I'm hoping you are
cooking up your own dr strategy join us
next time where we will share the recipe
to implement a hot dr pattern if you
liked this video and would like to see
more such content don't forget to Like
and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]